chris is quite nicely sat beside dawn
because then it's like being at home
getting on the sofa with the hair and
everything oh yes well I think I had
their first I have to say dawn dollar
water your wife yes yes
oh that's heard there now yeah yeah very
similar is what you're gonna be looking
at in another twenty years time I'll be
on live three by then she feels so
special but dawn might move on because
other dawn yeah because she likes
meeting men it seems even in your
presence Chris ah no oh yeah she does
she does she does well like anybody
would we've had a couple of things where
do we met Brad peas rice Zee at the
BAFTAs I think it was um he came over
and he was we were having a chat about
something or other and he was very nice
and I introduced him to Dawn and they
shook hands and then we kind of kept on
talking and then he fairly to talking to
somebody else or whatever and then after
a while I looked down and I realized
that she was still holding two of his
fingers I was like we better go to our
seats like okay and she said 41 seconds
I said what epilogue I held him for
weeks after that we wait for the what
other kind of awards bitter and um I'm
Bradley Cooper was there very nice guy
very kind of personable yes who that's
how he is and we were leaving and she
was getting her phone out of her bag and
I noticed something sparkling in this I
realized that she had stolen his Fork
she said that she was gonna auction it
for charity or something but every now I
get on home
I see a reading like this it's kind of
hard to feel like a sex symbol when your
wife is using another month the only
managed with Brad Pitt she only managed
to hold on to his fingers they that's
right so hands up everybody here who's
actually been kissed on the lips by Brad
Pitt
mr. sit down very handsome Matt very ha
but Colin Farrell beautiful right
beautiful matter yeah you're beautiful
now wait a minute you drive a car
there's as mrs. that name which keeps up
all the time but start again you know
they sort of see through yeah yeah